Hi.
Welcome.
I'm Vijay Menon.
I'm from the Dart team at
Google, and I'm going to be
talking about Dart JavaScript
Interoperability.
So Dart is a new programming
language that we're
developing at Google.
It's designed for structured
programming for the web, for
writing large scale web
applications, and it runs on
all modern browsers via
compilation to JavaScript, as
well as Dartium, a developer
version of Chromium where we
have native Dart support.
I'm not going to talk
a lot in this
presentation about Dart itself.
You can get a lot of general
information at dartlang.org.
So please take a look there.
In this talk, I'm going to
be talking about Dart and
JavaScript.
So as I said just before, Dart
compiles to JavaScript.
That lets us run Dart
applications on
all existing browsers.
But one of the questions that
we've been asked from the
start is, how do I mix Dart
code, my new Dart code, with
existing JavaScript code?
How do I use existing
libraries like
Google Maps and so on?
And I'm going to talk about
how you can do that today.
I'm going to give you examples
of how you can call existing
JavaScript, like Google Maps
or so on, from your Dart
application.
I'm going to show you how you
can invoke Dart code from
JavaScript.
I'll go through an example
with Twitter doing that.
And I'm going to show
all of this running
on different places.
And all of this works today.
So first, let me just give
you a quick demo
of what we can do.
I mentioned Google Maps is one
of the things we want to play
around with.
Google Maps is a JavaScript API
that we published, that
Google publishes, that you can
use, traditionally, from
JavaScript to write neat map
applications that are tailored
to your needs.
And we wanted to be able to do
that in Dart, and we can.
So here's an example of a simple
app based on one of the
published examples of
the Google Maps API.
Everything's written in Dart.
This is running in Firefox,
by the way.
And I can manipulate this.
This happens to have the
different cities that the Dart
team is based in.
I'm based in Seattle, but I'm
in Mountain View today.
So were I to go back, I can
run this little app
and see my path back.
If I want to go see my
colleagues in Denmark, well, I
should probably try flying, but
if I happen to already be
in London, I can navigate
to that.
So you get all of the nice
responsiveness, but the code
is all Dart.
And again, it runs on Firefox.
I can show you one other example
here on my Nexus 10.
Where here we're running on
Android, and if I open up the
browser here, you can see the
same application running here
as well, where I can go ahead
and navigate and everything
just works.
And again, this is a pure Dart
program that's interfacing
with a JavaScript API.
In this case, running
on Android.
So how does this work?
Well, I will show you
Maps in a little bit
more detail in a bit.
But first, I want to start with
a simpler example but
also using a real API.
So this is the Google Charts
API, which lets me draw graphs
and so on on my web page.
And it's a pretty big API, but
we're just going to focus on
some fairly simple things.
So as a Dart programmer, there
just happens to be a few
JavaScript APIs I'd like
to get access to.
I'd like to be able to, first of
all, put the Charts API on
my web page.
And then I'd like to be
able to access it.
And when you load up this
module, it loads into the page
as JavaScript context, this
JavaScript variable called
google.visualization.
And that, essentially, is the
entry point to all of the
JavaScript APIs dealing
with Charts.
And the ones that we're
interested in, in particular,
we're going to do a
bubble chart here.
There's a class BubbleChart we'd
like to instantiate using
the constructor that
you can see here.
And there's also a Draw function
where we can actually
feed it data that we want.
And there's also another
function that lets us
essentially massage data into
a format that is acceptable
for the Charts API.
So let's quickly see
what it looks like.
This is actually the web page
that we're going to render.
It's essentially setting up all
this data from Dart and
configuring it on the web page
using the Charts API.
So let's take a look at
how that was done.
Here I'm in the Dart Editor,
and this is the HTML file.
And we're including the Google
JavaScript APIs down here in
this first script.
That's a JavaScript script
and loading the JS API.
And our entire user level
program is just in this Dart
script, bubblechart.dart.
And so there's no other
JavaScript code
that we had to write.
We could just use the JavaScript
APIs directly from
our bubble chart example.
So here I'm in Dart code, and
the work is mainly done by
this function called
drawVisualization.
So this is essentially what gets
launched when the Charts
API's available, and I can go
ahead and populate the data.
So to show how it works, what
I'm going do is actually step
through this program
using the editor.
So I'm running here.
I'm launching an instance
of Dartium.
And so this is actually Dart
running natively on our
special version of Chromium.
But JS Interop works here well
too, and I get the nice
features of being able to step
through the browser.
So here I've called
drawVisualization, and I've
set a break point over here.
And the first thing I want to
show attention to is first of
all, before, at the very top,
in order to use JS Interop,
I'm just importing this
package js.dart.
And I'm prefixing it with JS.
So you'll see calls to JS dot
something or other throughout
this program.
Those are calls to the
JavaScript Interop library.
So the very first thing I do
in drawVisualization is,
remember, I mentioned
google.visualization is a
JavaScript package
that's loaded?
We can get a handle to that
from the Dart side by just
calling js.context.googl
e.visualization.
What js.contest is, is it's
essentially a proxy, a handle
to the global Dart context
of our web page.
And off of that context, I can
now access anything, for
example, Google Visualization.
And I'm just storing
that in the local
variable here called gviz.
Now, if you look at the panel
over here, on the right you
can see that the type
of gviz is proxy.
Proxy's a type provided
by the JS library.
So we get some sort of type
information, and that tells us
that this is a proxy to a
JavaScript object that we can
interact with.
So let's step through
this program.
So the very first thing we're
going to do is we actually
have data that we want to
feed into the Chart.
And we're creating
a regular Dart
array here called listData.
So if I just step over that,
you can see over here that
listData is of type array.
It's a regular Dart array.
Now, to feed it over to the
JavaScript side, I actually
need to convert the Dart array
to a JavaScript array, and
that's very easy.
I can just call this function
called js.array.
And if I step through this,
you'll see while listData has
the type array, arrayData is a
proxy to a JavaScript array.
I'm kind of breaking this up
into steps, but actually what
the Visualization Charts library
want you to do is
convert your array, now, to a
data table that it can use
with Charts.
And so one more step here
is actually to call
array to data table.
That's another one of the APIs
that we want to use.
And again, gviz is our handle
into the Visualization API.
So we call this JavaScript
function
arrayToDataTable here.
We pass it in a proxy to a
JavaScript array, and what we
get out is a proxy
to tableData.
And you can see the type of
tableData is also a proxy.
And so similarly, we
can create a map.
So configuration options for a
chart are a JavaScript map,
and we can easily create a
JavaScript map from a Dart map
by just wrapping it
in js.map here.
And now, we have options
that is also a proxy.
So I showed two ways
of creating
these proxies already.
One, you could take an existing
Dart list and convert
that to a JavaScript array.
You could take an existing Dart
map and convert that to a
JavaScript map.
But sometimes you
want to actually
instantiate a new object.
So again, going back to the
Chart API, we want to invoke
the bubble chart constructor
so we can
create a bubble chart.
And this syntax shows you how
you can use js.Proxy and
create a new one, essentially,
given a JavaScript
constructor, BubbleChart, and
an element on the DOM.
So we're just looking
up an element.
We're creating a bubble chart
with that element.
And what we get back, again, is
another proxy to the chart
in JavaScript.
And now, we can manipulate
that pretty naturally.
We can go ahead and draw the
data onto the chart that we've
got all set up here.
So I'm just going to continue,
and we can go ahead and look
at Dartium, and we see
the same exact
thing that we saw earlier.
But now this is running
in Dartium.
And again, here we're
mixing Dart and
JavaScript code in Dartium.
Just below here you can see--
I'll show some more examples
here-- but the Google API
actually provides many
things beyond Charts.
And so you can actually see a
little bit more here that
we're using to actually lazily
load the Visualization part of
the Google API from Dart and
asking for the core Chart
packages which actually
contains bubble chart.
And we're also setting up
this callback here for
drawVisualization.
So this new js.Callback, and
I'll go into a little bit more
detail on this in a moment,
is actually constructing a
JavaScript callback that
forwards to our
Dart function here.
So this is what it allows the
Dart program to call back into
JavaScript.
Great.
So that shows an
example again.
Here's a recap of that API.
One other example, very simple
example, I want to show where
we can pick up on callback is
a very special use case we
often get asked about
is JSONP.
Now, that's the ability to make
a request to a server and
have it send data in a format
that can be launched via
JavaScript.
And it's something that's--
it's a convention that's
used by a lot of APIs.
Twitter uses it.
And we want to make that
work with Dart.
And we can use Dart JS Interop
to make that work.
So let me show you our
Twitter example here.
And it's very, very simple.
In this case, all we need to
do, again, is to create a
callback to a display function,
but we need to give
it a name in the JavaScript
side.
So I showed on the last example
how you could read
stuff off of the JavaScript
context.
So for example, we had
js.context.google.visualization
in the last example.
Here you can see there's
also writables.
So what this is actually going
to do is create a top level
JavaScript variable, function
display, that's going to
forward to a Dart callback.
Callback here is creating
a callback out of a Dart
function that's usable
in JavaScript.
And once we have that,
everything else is easy.
We've set up this callback in
JavaScript that forwards back
to Dart, and now we can do the
standard JSONP of inserting a
request into our document.
And in this case, we're
going to Twitter.
We're making a search query
on Twitter about
things to do with Dart.
We're getting 20 items back,
and we're asking Twitter to
insert a callback to our
display function when
the data comes in.
And when the data comes in,
display is fired off from
JavaScript, which ends up
forwarding to the Dart
function here.
And again, we'll step through.
And even though this is
instantiated from the
JavaScript side, we can step
through the Dart code in the
editor here.
And so now, we've made this
request to Twitter.
It's come back.
We're in display, which
is Dart code here.
And data here is a proxy, as
we've seen before with other
things that we got
the JavaScript.
But we can manipulate
it pretty easily.
So for example, we can get the
results out of it, which is
another proxy object.
We can get the length.
In this case, it's a primitive
type, so we can actually type
that as an integer, and we see
that we get a length of 20.
We asked for 20 results.
We got 20 results.
And we can just iterate over
this fairly naturally now.
So for example, we
can go ahead and
get the first result.
We can get the user from the
first result, and that's typed
as a string.
So we can see that the name of
the current user-- this is
live data coming from Twitter so
I don't know what's on the
page at this point.
Linkify is just a Dart-specific
function that is
essentially just processing
that text to put some nice
links in there.
And we get that result.
And now we can render it on our
web page via Dart using
some nice features in Dart's
HTML API that essentially let
us very naturally build together
some HTML from that.
So let's--
now this would go ahead and
iterate 19 more times-- but
let's just go ahead and
jump ahead and see
what it looks like.
So here it is.
We've got the 20 different
Twitter results, and we've got
what people have been talking
about recently on Twitter
about Dart.
And when I ran it this morning,
one of the first
things I saw was a reference to
our Dart cookbook, which is
a cool link you can check
out and see stuff there.
But it's interesting to see
what people are doing.
So let's go back to
a different--
let's go back to our
slides here.
So what we saw here were proxies
going back and forth
between Dart and JavaScript.
And these aren't all the
proxies, but here are a couple
examples just showing what's
going on from our
Visualization example.
From our Charts example, we
actually had a Chart object on
the JavaScript side, but we were
able to create a proxy on
the Dart side to interact
with it.
Going the other way, we had
this drawVisualization
callback as well as the other
display callback in our
Twitter one, which looks exactly
the same as here.
And we were able to materialize
that as a proxy on
the JavaScript side.
So JavaScript can
call into Dart.
Dart objects can reach
into JavaScript going
the other way around.
So recapping, to create a Dart
proxy to JavaScript, we saw
three different ways
of doing that.
First, you can invoke a
JavaScript instructor and
create a proxy by creating
a new object.
You can create a new array
given a Dart array.
You can create a new map
given a Dart map.
And you can also create
callbacks in
JavaScript back to Dart.
And you've noticed the two
syntaxes, Callback.once and
Callback.many, and I'm going to
talk about that in a bit.
But they both, essentially,
expose a Dart function to the
JavaScript side.
All right.
Let's get back into a somewhat
more interactive example, the
Maps example.
And the Maps example is
interesting because it's more
of an interactive application.
I'm running things
many, many times.
So it actually highlights some
stuff about proxies that you
need to know about if you're
really pushing the boundaries
of what JS Interop can do.
So one of the things you have
to worry about JS Interop is
memory management because we're
essentially dealing with
two different heaps.
And although these look like
pointers from Dart objects to
JavaScript objects and vice
versa, that's kind of an
abstraction that we give the
programmer to make it easier
to write programs.
What this really looks like
under the hood is you really
have two disjointed heaps.
You have a heap of JavaScript
objects over here on the
right, and you have a
heap of Dart objects
over here on the left.
And we're doing the magic under
the hood to make it look
like you've got references
from one to the other by
essentially keeping these IDs
around and ensuring that you
get a consistent mapping
between the two.
One of the tricky issues here
is memory management.
I can show that very clearly.
If you look at this example
here, drawVisualization, for
example, is a callback, is a
function on the Dart side.
Now, normally the Dart VM will
garbage collect that out once
we're no longer using it.
But in our system, this id2 is
going to keep that call back
alive forever, unless we
explicitly get rid of it.
Or implicitly, I should say.
Sorry.
Unless we implicitly get rid
of it in some fashion.
We have to do something either
in the JS Interop layer or the
developer layer.
So the Dart garbage collector
only sees Dart objects is
essentially what the
problem is here.
And the JavaScript garbage
collector only sees
JavaScript.
So we need to do something to
help these manage memory.
So to show exactly the issues
here, let me go back to our
Maps example.
So Maps is a somewhat more
interesting example in that
it's again, more interactive.
As I showed you, you can
do many things with it.
You can interact and do multiple
steps with this, not
just one setting something
up and displaying it.
So let's just walk through this
code really quickly, and
then we can see it running.
So first of all, Main is
the entry point here.
And you'll notice like before
I have, instead of
google.visualization,
I have google.maps.
And js.context.google.maps is
giving me the proxy to the
Maps object.
But I want to use this Maps
object across multiple events.
So what I have to
do is retain it.
Now, if I don't retain this,
I'm essentially going to go
ahead and collect it.
Or the JS Interop layer is going
to go ahead and collect
it at the end.
It's going to de-allocate
all those handles so
it can clear memory.
So if I don't retain
it, I'll be able to
use it in this method.
But in some callback that
happens at some later point,
it will be an invalid proxy.
So retain keeps it around.
And you'll notice this pattern
here of I have these global
variables, maps,
directionsDisplay,
directionsService.
I want to use retain to make
sure that those global
variables are valid beyond
a single event.
So you can see here
that, again, I'm
creating a map of options.
So to create the options, I
populate it with this map.
I can use--
again, Maps here is referring
to the API.
I can use ROADMAP to indicate
what kind of map.
I can create a
latitude/longitude object,
feed this all in.
I don't have to use retain here
because these are all
just used in the process of
constructing one Google map.
This is the call to construct
a map on a
certain canvas element.
And then, display is a component
that actually
displays the results.
And that's updated
interactively, so I need to go
ahead and retain that.
That's one of my other
global variables.
I'm using this across events,
so I need to retain it.
And then finally,
directionsService is actually
the bridge in the Maps
JavaScript API that goes and
talks to Google servers and
actually gets the directions
information.
So again, we're going through
the JavaScript APIs, se we
need to initialize this service,
and we need to retain
it so we can use it
for new queries.
So we're essentially setting up
our handlers here so when I
go from Seattle to Mountain View
or Portland or whatever,
it initiates a new request.
So it's going to calculate
a route.
It's going to figure out the
start and end based on the
options I've given it.
And it's going to
route a request.
And again, the request here
is initiating a callback.
So I'm calling into JavaScript
and saying, when this request
is done, call back this
Dart function.
And I use js.Callback.many
to set it up.
And it's an anonymous
closure in here.
So I don't actually have
to allocate a function.
I can do this nicely in line,
which essentially says in Dart
code, OK, when the request comes
back, well, either it's
OK and I'm going to go ahead and
display the directions, or
I wasn't able to compute.
These are different continents,
and it's going to
suggest that you fly instead.
So let's go ahead and run
this from Dartium.
It's the same app I showed you
before on both the Android
device and Firefox.
And here I'm starting
in Seattle.
I go down to Portland.
So notice that these are
different events.
So every time I'm doing this,
I'm actually clearing out
proxies and then allocating new
ones to make a new call.
Now, in this case, you'll notice
everything's working as
usual, but I have this
print message here.
And it's calling this function
called proxyCount count.
And that's more of a debugging
tool for you to tell if you're
using this app in more of
an interactive way.
If you're using this library in
a more interactive way, it
tells you, essentially, how
much is live and whether
you're leaking proxies.
And you can see here that
the first time I
called it, it was six.
The next time I called
it, it was seven.
Let's go ahead and do this
a few more times.
We'll go from Denmark to Germany
to St. Petersburg.
Now, every time I call this, I
see that the number of live
proxies is increasing, so that
should be a warning sign.
And in fact, I talked about
Callback.once and
Callback.many.
That's a tool here that you can
use to manage the proxies.
Now, it turns out the difference
between this is
that Callback.once is
essentially telling the
system, I have a callback.
It's only allocated--
It's only invoked once.
Callbacks, by definition, have
to live across events, so we
don't clean them up
automatically.
But if you do Callback.once, it
will fire once, and it will
clean itself up.
If you do Callback.many, it will
create that callback, and
it will persist.
So it's essentially a callback
that you might
call many, many times.
In this particular case, every
time I make a new request,
every time I have a different
pair of cities, I'm making a
new request with
a new callback.
So I'm creating a callback
every time.
And because I'm using
Callback.many, I have an extra
proxy running every time.
But in this case, this callback
only gets invoked
once, so I can go ahead
and make this once.
So even though the number of
live proxies is increasing
very slowly, so unless you're
running this app for a long,
long time, you wouldn't
necessarily notice this.
We build large scale
apps that will--
we want to be able to run these
apps for weeks and weeks
without causing issues
in the browser.
And so if you're writing that
kind of app, you really do
want to make sure you don't
have these kind of leaks.
And again, here, by using once,
we can get the effect we
want even in this very
interactive application and
clean up after ourselves.
And in this case, we
have a nice small
constant number of proxies.
And that's what we
want to see.
We want to see, as we use this
app, the number of proxies is
some small constant.
And in this case, 6.
And, therefore, we know that
we're not leaking.
Great.
So again, the takeaway from this
is you do need to think a
little bit about managing memory
carefully if you have
an interactive application.
You can keep a proxy alive
with js.retain.
You can release it when you're
done with js.release.
So the common pattern is you
have globals or such.
We have single versus multiple
execution callback, so
js.Callback.once, and this
should be js.Callback.many for
multiple execution.
And you can track the total
number of proxies for
debugging by using proxyCount.
So thanks.
You can learn more about this.
Learn more about Dart in
general by going to
dartlang.org.
And one of the new things that
we've put up there on
dartlang.org is a cookbook that
will give you a lot of
quick start recipes on
how to use Dart,
including JavaScript Interop.
We'll have some information
there.
If you want to learn more about
the JavaScript Interop
library and how to get started
with it and add it to your
application, go to our
GitHub page that has
the JavaScript package.
It will show you how to get
started with a simple hello
app, and they'll show you docs
on all the APIs we provided,
as well as all the samples
that we've shown today.
And Source Code, it's a
collaborative project, and we
get updates from people both
inside and outside of Google
who've made lots of big
contributions to it.
Thank you.